[Music]
foreign
when I was 12.
dystonia is a neurological disease that
basically means that some part of my
brain is just a little bit unusual
for me it was in one leg that was in my
right hand and it was in my left leg and
then I had Tremors and then my speech
was very slurred I struggled with it
through high school I somehow stopped
running with my right hand and taught
myself how to write with my left hand so
overcoming obstacles is just something
that I'm used to finding solutions to
after business school it became really
really tough to walk and I remember
walking 56th Avenue in New York City
it's really a long block and those
blocks would take 45 minutes it just
became really hard and I just started to
look like what would my life in a
wheelchair look like
I'm a nerd this is the major theme of
the story I built a spreadsheet and the
spreadsheet was like what are the pros
of brain surgery over the cause of brain
surgery but I disrupted the analysis I
realized I had nothing to lose but to
have brain surgery
eight weeks after I was walking in the
same block 56th Avenue and I realized
what was taking 45 minutes took four
minutes and I got to Sixth Avenue and I
still makes me much like to start like
crying and laughing and I just had never
felt that feeling and probably since I
was 15 years old
I started running
um December 4th 2006. for anyone who
runs out there's you know you always
remember your first race and you go
around with the escalation process I did
probably a couple more 10ks and then I
was like if I can do a 10K why not do a
half marathon
the thing with me when I'm running is I
actually have to think about every step
so I have to accomplish the thing like
lay my foot flat lay my foot flat words
most a lot of people just Pitter powder
but I always had my sights on the
greatest marathon in the world which I
believe is nerd sleeper I thought I did
in 2018 it is probably really one of the
best marathons you could ever run that
was just a dream come true
I had written about in my GSB essay that
my dream of life was to one day run a
marathon
it has truly been remarkable what
science has done to change my life and
to give me the miracle of running
I always tell myself every morning that
I have a superhero cape and for me
Women's Health was just super
interesting because we've been fighting
for representation in the healthcare
field the beauty about Telehealth is you
can do it in the privacy of your living
room you can really tell your Healthcare
needs a non-judgmental way I've made a
conscious decision to use my platform to
talk about how this affects marginalized
communities
people who are usually going to get
caught in The Fray are people of color
people are blurring economic societies
and people in marginalized communities I
eat transgender people simple health is
a reproductive care company which offers
services to women and people born with
ovaries right now we currently do birth
control so you come online you go on
simplehelp.com you figure out an online
consultation a doctor reviews it he gets
back to you with your medication and
then we sent to Pharmacy and you should
get your prescription within three to
five days all discreetly from your
living room with a judgment free
doctor's appointment so then we're super
proud of that
to really having a business around
longitudinal care around reproductive
health no one's done it yet but I tell
people all the time this is what the GSB
does for you it makes you dream as big
as you can
my thesis simple health is that we have
to keep on continuing to fight for
people's rights to privacy of their
health care needs reproductive care or
not
[Music]
one of the things I'd always said to
myself is when I grow up and be a great
CEO I'm really going to try and create a
company where the employee Workforce
matches the patient or the consumer base
I am super proud to say that we are 47
people of color we're 46
lgbtqia plus we're 36 disabled we're 10
single parents I believe we're six
percent veterans we don't do this by
checking boxes we just truly do it by
attracting the right Talent
I had always known I wanted to go to
business school since I was probably
seven years old and I think my parents
thought what is she talking about we're
like living in Trinidad how does she
even know what business school is
in terms of like what Stanford has done
for me it has just surpassed any
expectation that I ever thought about
has changed my entire life the way I
communicate has made me the leader I am
today
the power of leadership the power of
empathy and really the power of
communication so professionally that's
what I took away personally just an
incredible amount of like friends and um
foreign
I had such a great
bunch of classmates that never made me
feel different
never made me feel
[Music]
disabled but
I think because of that is really why I
can be the great leader I am today or
the person I am today because of
My Tribe you really are a product of
your tribe and I think that the GSB out
of everything else is going to be such a
great tribe
foreign
[Music]